[Musique]
depuis 40 ans on s'amuse avec la science
dans le magazine des débrouillards et
pour son infatigable illustrateur il ya
de quoi célébrer les années ont passé et
on voit les enfants on voit les
deuxièmes dix fois la troisième
génération donc c'est un bel
accomplissement malheureusement vous
informer que les penseurs scientifiques
ce ne pourra pas être avec nous tout a
commencé avec le succès de ce premier
livre d'expériences scientifiques pour
les jeunes son auteur félix maltais
décide alors de lancer en janvier 1982
un magazine d'abord baptisé je me petit
débrouille à l'époque ça n'existait pas
ce genre d'activité le scientifique qui
s'adresse à une clientèle aussi jeune
le populaire magazine a propulsé tout un
mouvement avec entre autres des ateliers
des quinze jours et un moment avec une
émission de télévision intitulée les
débrouillards co animé par marie soleil
figa et gregory charles quint produits
qui parfumait se vend beaucoup mieux que
le même produit pour parfumer on est
devenus des vrais spécialistes des
troncs j'aime assez fort pour tous à
deux réseaux j'ai aussi un et
d'admiration je crois encore à
l'importance on s'est posé à qu'elles
sont très très longtemps à propos du
déficit qu'il y avait entre les garçons
et les filles en sciences mais je pense
que l'idée brillante c'est une partie de
la superpole la structure mais une
partie de la solution
j'admire les gens qui continuent à face
je serai toujours toujours à leur
service pour la biochimiste marianne des
hôtels marissal le magazine a été source
d'émerveillement tu es la section des
expériences que j'attendais avec le plus
d'impatience
je pense que j'ai coûté cher en
bicarbonate de soude qui en colorant
alimentaire à mes parents mais je pense
à me aussi donné le goût de vulgariser
et de communiquer moi aussi la science
ce que je fais maintenant puis j'ai
aussi été animatrice en quinze jours des
débrouillards qu'acheter au cg
aujourd'hui le mouvement à plus d'une
expérience dans son sac avec ses trois
magazines et son balado une nouvelle
émission de télé est en chantier jacques
goldstyn ne compte pas déposer ses
crayons de sitôt je vais rester jusqu'à
la fin de ma vie avec les débrouillards
car après tout débrouillard anges aux
débrouillards toujours ici jouer
philippe ouimet radio canada montréal
mais
[Musique]